[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello,
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
Product Manager at Google.
And I'm joined here by one of my
colleagues, Jeremy Lewi, who's
going to tell us a
little bit about Kubeflow
and his talk at
KubeCon here this week.
What can you tell us about
developing applications
on Kubeflow?
JEREMY LEWI: Hi.
So what we learned at
Google is that if you're
building ML systems, you have
a complicated distributed
system that requires lot
of dev ops challenges.
So with Kubeflow, we decided
to take advantage of containers
and Kubernetes to try to
build a ML platform that could
help solve these challenges.
And at KubeCon,
what I'll be demoing
is an end-to-end example of
solving those challenges using
Kubeflow, building
a ML product where
the product, in this case,
is summarizing GitHub issues.
So after deploying Kubeflow,
we can access JupyterHub
and use JupyterHub
to launch a notebook
for our initial
experimentation and analysis.
Here I'm using a
custom notebook image
that has all the
libraries we need
for this particular example.
And I just click Spawn
to go ahead and spawn
that particular notebook.
Once Jupyter starts,
we can go ahead
and navigate through
the menus to find
our particular notebook.
And this particular notebook
was developed by Hamal Hussein
for this particular example.
And we can see that it
has all the steps needed
to develop a model.
So first we download some data.
Then we pre-process the data.
Once we're done
pre-processing the data,
we're going to go ahead and
define our model architecture.
And we can display the
actual model architecture
using the notebook.
Once we're done
developing the model,
we can actually train the model.
And you can see it's running
for a couple of iterations.
Once we're done
training the model,
we can generate some
predictions in the notebook.
And this is great, but we only
used a subset of the data.
So now we're going to go ahead
and train the model at scale
using distributed training.
But first, to do that,
we have to take the code
and put it into a Python file.
We can then use the Python
file to build the Docker image.
So this is the
Python file with all
of the code, which is
basically just copied directly
from the notebook image.
We can then go to
the command line,
and we can deploy
a custom TensorFlow
job, which is a custom
resource in Kubernetes
that we created to make it easy
to run distributed training.
So we've gone ahead
and deployed that job.
And now we can look at the
actual spec for that job.
And basically it's a bunch
of pod template specs, where
one pod template spec describes
each replica in our distributed
training job.
While the job is
training, we can go ahead
and launch TensorBoard,
and use TensorBoard
to see how well our
model is training
and what the performance is.
Once we're done
training the model,
we can take advantage of
Seldon to deploy the model.
And to use Seldon,
all we have to do
is implement the
predict function.
We can then build the
Docker image with our model.
We can then deploy it using
Seldon's custom resource.
So here we're just launching
the Seldon deployment
for our particular model.
After we've deployed
it, we can go ahead
and see what the spec is.
And we can see that the spec
is very similar to a deployment
spec.
The main difference is we can
specify an inference graph that
consists of the models.
And once we're done
with the models,
we can go ahead and check out
our actual web application
to generate predictions.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Summarizing GitHub issues.
So you take as input--
your data input is, I
guess, a GitHub project.
And you're going to
build a summary of all
of the issues in that project?
JEREMY LEWI: Actually, we
summarize individual issues.
So one of the problems, if
you're maintaining a GitHub
project, is a lot of
times, people file issues
with uninformative
titles, in a large part
because maybe they're
filing a bug report
and they don't know what
the actual problem is.
So after you do a
little bit of triaging
and you find out what
the actual problem is,
you want to go back and give the
issue a more informative title
to maintain the hygiene
of your project.
But that requires a lot
of toil and manual labor.
So this is something
that you might
want to automate by using ML
to see if you can automatically
generate a title from an issue.
So as that issue gets updated,
as people provide comments
and feedback on the issue,
you can automatically
generate a title that better
summarizes that issue.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Will this
help with dedupe, perhaps?
Maybe duping different issues
in GitHub and helping developers
spend more time on the
issues that matter?
JEREMY LEWI: It could be
extended, potentially,
to solve that problem.
Because one of the things with
this particular application,
you can actually learn
embeddings of GitHub issues,
and those can become
features for other models.
And one of those models
could potentially
be to identify duplicate issues.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
Is this something that we're
going to use, actually,
at Google, perhaps, ourselves?
JEREMY LEWI: Right now it's
an exploratory product.
So it's actually developed
by Hamal Hussein, who's
a data scientist at GitHub.
And so we took
that and we started
to try to productionize
it using Kubeflow.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And what
are some of the technologies
that this is built on top of?
I assume, at least, Kubernetes,
maybe TensorFlow, right?
Anything else fit into
sort of the framework?
JEREMY LEWI: Yeah.
So there's a lot of
different packages
that we incorporate
to build this product.
So we start off by
deploying JupyterHub,
which is a multi-user
Jupyter notebook solution.
And we use that to give our
data scientists the ability
to explore data and
build their models.
And usually they're using
TensorFlow for that.
When they're done doing
that, then they sort of
want to train at
scale, in this case,
using distributed TensorFlow
running on Kubernetes.
They then have to build
and deploy a model.
In this case, they're
using Selden I/O. And then
after they deploy
that model, they also
have to deploy a simple
web application to actually
make it more consumable.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
So how hard is this
to set up for an end user
who has a GitHub repo?
JEREMY LEWI: So
to set up Kubeflow
is just a couple of commands,
and we provide all the source
in our examples repo.
So anybody should be able to
try to set it up and start
serving a model.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
five minutes to wow.
JEREMY LEWI: Sure.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Great.
Thanks, Jeremy.
JEREMY LEWI: Thank you.